All right, all right. Welcome back to
the channel where we talk about
copywriting and the creator economy. We
have a special one for you today where
we're going to be diving into the seven
books that make my marketing degree
practically irrelevant. And if I haven't
met you, my name is Allan Drago, aka El
Copy Goat. We're going to be diving
right in today. Back to referencing the
marketing degree. I actually have a few
degrees. I have a business degree, a
bachelor's in business. I have a
bachelor's in marketing and I have a
theology degree from when I was a
pastor, which I'm no longer a pastor. I
still love Jesus, but I am no longer a
pastor at a church. That's the only
thing that's changed. But in today's
video, I'm going to be diving into seven
books and one special bonus book. So,
you're going to have to wait till the
end to see that one. But let's go ahead
and dive into the books cuz I believe we
are in an economy where college is
becoming almost practically irrelevant,
especially with the access to the
resources that we have today. And these
books are about to prove my point
because if you read, study, and master
these, I guarantee you will learn
infinitely more than spending 40 grand
to 100 grand to go somewhere to sit in a
classroom to have someone who's not
lived the life, who's built the business
to teach you a bunch of theories and
concepts that are outdated, that they
don't work. It just doesn't make any
sense today. And I am living proof of
that where these books, these books,
which we're going to find out here in a
second. Oh, I dropped one. All right.
Starting with the first book, The Art
and Business of Online Writing. The
first time that I read this book was
four or five years ago. I've been
writing blogs and posting things like
that, but I wasn't able to dominate a
social media presence like I have today
with over 6,000 followers on Twitter
right now at the recording of this
video, almost 4,000 on YouTube. And
that's not including Instagram and
TikTok and things like that. [music] And
that is because the skill set that I
built in this book, writing hooks,
writing content, telling stories,
transitions, captivating people. This is
not something you can just prompt into
Chat GPT or Claude or whatever. These
are skill sets that you have to learn to
craft rhythm, taste, hooks. Like there's
just so much juice in this. And
honestly, too many people underestimate
the value of writing online, whether
you're a thought leader, you're building
in the creator economy, you're a
copywriter. Hopefully, you value the art
of writing. This is one of the books
that everyone must read if you want to
have a valuable [music] skill set
that'll go on and on forever. Every
marketer needs to read this. Book number
two, most people have not heard of this
one. It is called Insanely Simple by Ken
Segall. So, Ken Segall was a creative
director
of the marketing agency, the advertising
agency that was helping Apple in its
heyday. I mean, think iPod, iPhone, Mac.
[music] Like he helped work directly
with Steve Jobs to launch these
campaigns. In fact, the author of this
book, Ken Segall, is the one that named
the Mac, the iMac. They were going to
call it the Mac Man.
>> [music]
>> And Steve Jobs was like, "No, I can't I
can't think of a better name than the
Mac Man." And he says, "Let's call it
the iMac." And that turned into the
iPhone and the iPod and all that. So,
you can credit Ken Segall for that. The
premise behind this book is how Steve
Jobs built Apple into the largest
company in the world as fast as it did
based on the concept of simplicity. And
one of my favorite quotes in this book
is, "Nobody's company has ever failed
from being too simple." In fact, this is
more relevant now than ever before in
2026 where we are just so complex in our
businesses, our offers, our messaging,
our communication, our teams, our
staffing, our tech stack, every single
thing that we do, especially in the
creator economy. We are just so
scattered and all over the place because
we can build as fast as we can. We can
offer and ship and create products as
fast as we can. This [music] book is a
litmus test to make sure that you are on
the right track and it'll give you the
systems, the ideas, and [music] the
mental fortitude to be like, "Man, am I
doing things as simply, effectively, and
with excellence as possible?" Absolutely
fantastic book. Could not recommend this
more. The next book, probably many of
you have heard this. The Almanac of
Naval Ravikant. If you're in the creator
economy and you have not read this book,
shame on you. Shame on you. This book
This book has literally changed my life.
The biggest concept in this book that
has affected me is the concept of
leverage and compound interest. I was
working at corporate [music] companies,
climbing the ladder, all these things.
And when he showed his leverage ladder
on how to actually build leverage
[music] more so with like media and code
are his top two leverage ladders. I'm
not a coder, but I'm big into media,
things like YouTube, [music] podcasting,
writing online, things like that. When
you pair this book with this book,
right, The Art and Business of Writing
Online with The Almanac of Naval
Ravikant, this is a dangerous duo,
right? Cuz this is going to give you the
the systems and the ideas on how to
think about building your business,
building [music] in assets instead of
assignments. Like just This book is
incredibly good for thinking differently
about your future and how you can
compound into the creator economy, which
is [music] honestly the spawn of how I
created Copy Creator Club. Copy Creator
Club is a byproduct [music]
of this book because I realized that
copywriters were stuck in this client
chase, always chasing the next gig,
always chasing the next client and the
next paycheck when really you can use
things like media, like other
leverage-based assets and actually
create a copywriting career that is
based [music] on the creator economy and
not based on the client economy. All
that came from this book. Highly
recommend. Next one is the [music]
golden standard, Expert Secrets, Russell
Brunson. Even though this book has been
out for, I don't know, over a decade or
whatever it is, the the structure in
this, I just reread this again for like
the third time this year. This is still
to me the golden standard of building a
personal brand, which by the way, is so
much stronger than some sort of
logo-faced brands, especially [music] in
2026 at the time of this recording where
if you go online to any social media
profile, you'll notice that personal
brands have significantly more
followers, likes, comments, engagements,
and fans than brands that are just
logo-faced. Russell Brunson perfectly
explains this [music] with ClickFunnels.
He talks about ClickFunnels is only what
it is today because of Russell Brunson,
because he wrote books and because he
posted media online, [music] because he
did podcasts and he spoke at conferences
and he injected ClickFunnels into those
conversations. So, if you're building
anything, you're selling products,
you're selling a business, you're
actually selling yourself first. And
this book teaches you how to sell
yourself first, how to build yourself
into a personal brand, how to have the
character arc, the stories, the offers,
persuasion tactics to sell yourself
first. Fantastic book. Read it multiple
times. Here, this is the golden
standard. Highly recommend if you are in
the creator economy building an online
personal brand. [music] Here's one that
most people would have never guessed to
be on the list. That is 33 Strategies of
War by Robert [music] Greene. Now, this
obviously is a book of stories of war.
So, people you're trying to beat and you
can think of them as your competitors in
the business world. But more than that,
more than that, what this teaches you is
how to think like an entrepreneur that
is people-focused first, right? Serving
first instead of selling first. You have
to be able to get into the heads of your
people, their pains, their dreams, their
[music] desires, their hopes, their
obstacles, and figuring out how to do
that takes an enormous amount of human
nature, psychology study. And this book
is jam-packed
with how humans think, why they think,
how they make decisions, how you can
strategically make decisions, which
makes [music] you more persuasive. It
makes you more dangerous in your niche.
And if you have the ability to connect
the dots, right? Like this is not going
to connect the dots of sales and
persuasion for you. But if you can read
this and start to understand how these
tactics actually apply to your business,
then this is a very interesting, very
powerful [music] book for your business.
All right, the next one is by my friend
Brian Kurtz, Overdeliver. There are two
concepts in this book that I just I have
to rave about because it [music] changed
the way I do business. Two concepts. One
is RFM, recency, frequency, monetary.
This changed the way that I sell and
upsell and do business with my customers
is finding people who have bought from
me the most recent, who buy from me the
most frequently, [music] and who spend
the most money. RFM. And in that, I've
been able to curate hyper list of buyers
[music] in my business so I can be more
congruent in the offers that I make them
and I make them better offers. I make I
solve better problems for them and they
[music] become more raving fans because
of how I serve them just by looking at
the RFM data. So, I know who are my best
customers, what do they want, what have
they bought from me, what are they
asking for, and serving that small list
of very best customers way more heavily
than trying to solve problems for
everyone. That changed my life. The
other thing is measuring LTV, lifetime
value. That's another thing that he
teaches in this book. Which by the way,
if you don't know who Brian Kurtz is,
Brian Kurtz managed over $9 billion in
direct response mail at a publishing
company called Boardroom. They were one
of the biggest publishing companies in
the world. He is no schmuck. In fact,
he's worked with the greatest
copywriters and direct response
advertisers in the world. If anybody
knows how to sell and build a
multi-billion dollar company, it's this
guy, okay? So, [music] back to LTV. LTV
means lifetime value. Optimizing your
business to serve [music] your customers
for the lifetime value. Most
entrepreneurs and marketers and bro
dudes on TikTok are are all about
selling stuff the [music] first time.
They don't care if they sell crap, they
don't care if the people ever come back.
But not in this book. He teaches you how
to build a lifetime business, one that
that lasts [music] decades and decades
and decades. And that is what I'm
interested I'm interested in serving
people that want to buy every single
thing I ship because everything I ship
is excellent, it's amazing, [music] it
solves their problem. And he teaches you
the systems to do that. Highly, highly
recommend. I mean, this guy's built. I
mean, a multi-billion dollar business
and you're you're going to tell me that
a college degree is going to be better
than what he has to tell. It's not,
okay? It's not. Fantastic [music] book.
We could not end this video without an
incredible copywriting book, The Goat
Copywriting Book, The Adweek Copywriting
Handbook by Joe Sugarman. If you were to
read one copywriting book, which every
marketer and entrepreneur should read a
copywriting [music] book because
copywriting is sales in writing, which
everything is written. YouTube scripts
are written, texts are written, pitch
decks are written, emails are written.
Everything is written. And if you know
how to write, then you know how to
persuade, [music] especially if you know
how to copy write. This is the one book,
if you were going to read any book on
copywriting and say cuz I get this
question all the time, "Al, what's the
one book I should read?" Well, you
should read a bunch of them, but if
you're only going to read one, it would
be this one because he does [music] the
best job, in my opinion, of breaking
down the timeless strategies for
copywriting, but the but the timely
tactics [music]
on how to apply them. He makes it really
simple, really easy to understand. He
does it with great storytelling, great
examples. I mean, it's just [music] an
absolutely wonderful book. You can get
it for 20 bucks. This, honestly, is what
most of these gurus online regurgitate
in their 997 courses. They're going to
sell you a course for a grand and
they're just regurgitating Joe Sugarman.
So, that and Cashvertising. They
regurgitate that one all the time. But
this is your go-to book if you're ever
going to up your game as a copywriter,
this is the way to do it. And as
promised, those are the seven books that
I say absolutely make all of my degrees
irrelevant, including my marketing
degree. But one that I'd love to gift
you for free is Meaningful [music]
Marketing. This is my book. I wrote this
book
over 3 years ago and it is 38 simple
principles to help make your marketing
actually match your mission. It's a book
less about direct response advertising
and it's more about the emotions and the
meanings behind the marketing you do and
the principles that help you feel good
about the marketing cuz there's a lot of
sleazy people out there. There's a lot
of marketing bros on [music] the TikTok
that really just want to sell and make
money. And don't get me wrong, I love
selling and making money. This whole
channel is about selling and making
money with copywriting, but I want to do
it for a long time and you want to do it
for a long time. We want to be around
here posting videos, writing content
online, building relationships with
people and helping the people in our
niche because if we sell stuff, but we
don't help people, well, then this is
not the channel for you. You can go
somewhere else. But if we sell stuff and
we help people, then we need the
principles to help us align in making
sure [music] that we're doing meaningful
marketing. And I'm going to gift it to
you for free. You can grab a free PDF
version of this book. You're more than
welcome to go grab it on Amazon. It has
five-star reviews, straight-up five, not
even a four-star. It has five-star
reviews, [music] but you can grab it.
Link in the description below. You can
get the free Kindle version for free.
Once you hit the link in the description
below, it'll put you on my email list.
I'll send it to you. [music] You're more
than welcome to unsubscribe from my
email list if you don't want to be on
there, but I highly recommend hanging
out at least for a couple [music] days,
getting some incredible emails from me,
my great storytelling, and I'm going to
show you amazing examples of how to sell
with story in email [music] every single
day. Well, that wraps this up for this
video. If you enjoyed it, hit like and
subscribe so I know that you want more
content like this. Appreciate your
support and all the things. And if you
could, leave a comment down below. What
book did I not mention that [music] you
would consider absolutely worthy of
wiping away these college degrees and
just saying, "Read this [music] book
instead." I think I hit some really good
bangers, but I'd love to hear your
recommendations [music]
down below. What should I read? What
haven't I read? What books aren't on
this list that need to be on [music]
this list? I hope that's helpful for
you. If you want me to do more
breakdowns like this, let me know in the
comments below. Catch you on the next
one.